so how much student loan debt do you
guys have uh she has 203,000 right now
oo what's her degree in uh anesthesia
good okay and is she how much is she
making a year uh combined we gross about
340 combin 340 okay so that's the
student loans and then any other debt
how much do youall owe on the cars uh we
have two vehicles they're both a little
over 50,000 we owe on them $100,000 in
cars even though your income can
somewhat justify it we don't want it
more than half of your annual income so
it technically could justify it but
almost for the act of it I would just I
would get rid of them how much do you
think you could sell them for uh we
could probably clear 10 on each there's
a radical mindset shift that that needs
to happen for you guys you've been doing
your plan and it's not working you make
$350,000 and I'm not trying to come down
on you too hard Dustin but there's
people listening right now that think
holy crap